bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public la
promesse est dans le titre donné
naissance à l'actualité se mettre au
service des citoyens vous proposer des
clés de compréhension des mutations de
notre société et des enjeux de cette
présidentielle justement avec le
scandale orpea les questions du grand
âge la dépendance ont déboulé dans cette
campagne les ehpad privés sont dans le
collimateur le sénat créer une
commission d' enquête pour vérifier s'il
s'agit de dérive isolés ou de
maltraitance systémique ce sera notre
débat dans une minute notre débats
d'actu les électeurs ont la parole les
reporter de public sénat parts à votre
rencontre ce soir des éleveurs qui
réagissent tu une loi qui leur impose
une formation au bien être animal c'est
comme si on inscrivait un médecin à une
formation premiers secours disent
certains d'entre eux et puis je vous
parlais de transformation de la société
française en voilà une la loi va bientôt
nous permettre de changer de nom
beaucoup plus facilement avancées
féministes liberté supplémentaire aux
menaces sur la famille les avis
divergent et ça nous promet un débat
enflammé tout à l'heure mais d'abord le
fonctionnement des ehpad passés au
crible par les sénateurs famille au
caire l'état at il manqué de vigilance
dans le scandale orpea c'est ce que
cherchera à déterminer la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale
après les révélations de maltraitance
dans les ehpad les sénateurs veulent
tirer au clair la question des contrôles
de ces établissements comme le résume le
sénateur alain milon contrôler ce qui a
été contrôlée ou pas contrôlée par le
passé et puis
regardez ce qui se fait dans les autres
pays mais c'est avant tout pour
contrôler l'action de l'état ces
dernières années il ya les problèmes au
niveau des contrôles absolument c'est
pas normal qu'on arrive à ce type de
situation donc
la raison de plus pour enquêter refus de
soins personnels en sous-effectif couche
rationnés dans son livre enquête les
fossoyeurs le journaliste victor
castanet avait révélé de très graves
dysfonctionnements dans les
établissements du groupe orpea des
pratiques pourtant passé sous le radar
des autorités de contrôle comme les ars
mais pour la gauche il faut aller encore
plus loin et remettre en cause le modèle
de la rentabilité dans la prise en
charge du grand âge la question de fond
c'est de savoir pourquoi dans certaines
catégories d pad il ya un ratio de
personnel par personne hébergée qui est
faible et pourquoi dans d'autres il est
plus élevé donc on permettra de faire de
l'argent sur le fait d'héberger et de
prendre soin des personnes âgées eh bien
on n'en changera rien au système donc se
polariser sur la question des contrôles
se polariser éventuellement sur la
responsabilité de l'état c'est faire
l'impasse sur la responsabilité de ceux
qui gèrent ces établissements de ceux
qui font tourner ces établissements la
commission qui devrait débuter ses
travaux en mars veut notamment
auditionner des membres du gouvernement
une façon pour la majorité de droite au
sénat d'attaqué l'exécutif sur un sujet
sensible à deux mois de la
présidentielle alors justement on va en
parler de ces enjeux politiques et de
cette commission d' enquête du sénat je
vous présente mes invités monique lubin
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
sénatrice socialiste des landes vice
président de la commission des affaires
sociales bernard bonne bon soir
sénateurs et l'air de la loire membre de
la commission des affaires sociales vous
êtes en chargé de mener les travaux de
cette commission d' enquête sur les
épaules avec la sénatrice socialiste
michel monier à vos côtés et puis
d'autres sénateurs évidemment vous
n'êtes pas tous les deux tout seul serge
guérin bonsoir bonsoir de retrouver vous
êtes sociologues spécialisés en jeux du
vieillissement de la solidarité
professeur directeur du pôle santé aline
sec et vous publiez aux services de la
ville et métiers du service à la
personne c'est aux éditions fauves avec
nous également en visioconférence en
duplex romain gizolme qui est directeur
de l'association des directeurs au
service des personnes âgées vous
regrouper bonsoir les ehpad et les
établissements de services à domicile
bienvenue à vous aussi au soir bonsoir
les ti sacre pas éditrice poétique
bonsoir laetitia mes côtés comme tous
les mardis et jeudis dans cette émission
bernard bonne je commence avec vous
puisque vous vous mener cette commission
denquête qu'est ce que vous en espérez
beaucoup de choses quand même parce que
on va pouvoir travailler effectivement
en toute liberté par rapport à aux
enjeux politiques actuels c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure je crois que le
fait que les élections présidentielles
dans peu de temps avec donc un
gouvernement qui sera peut-être
différent probablement différent au mois
de juin nous permettra de voir toute la
latitude pour faire des propositions et
faire cette enquête c'est cette mission
en tout cas en toute liberté mais on
peut aussi vous dire on est en pleine
campagne présidentielle les additions
voix avoir lieu pendant cette campagne
est donc elles auront un impact
politique fort oui bien sûr pas ça oui
thomas tiquement on va enfin ils seront
médiatisé va montré des carences
effectivement des uns et des autres par
rapport à ce manque d'attention auprès
des personnes âgées mais là aussi on en
parlera certainement tout à l'heure sans
généraliser en parlera de tout mais les
maisons qui accueillent des personnes
âgées ont façonné les ai pas de priver
pas seulement les ehpad privé à but
lucratif mais aussi les ehpad privée
associative aux autres on les publics et
aussi des résidences autonomie je crois
qu'il faut pas oublier aucun des
établissements qui accueillent
aujourd'hui des personnages et où il
peut y avoir des problèmes alors il y en
a pas partout je crois qu'effectivement
il faut pas pas imaginer que partout on
a des difficultés comme celles qui ont
été montrés mais il y en a trop et il
faut absolument qu'on réagisse à ce trou
alors ça ce sera effectivement l'un des
thèmes du débat est-ce que ça systémique
ou pas ou est ce qu'on parle d'eux de
dérives très graves mais de derry et pas
d'un système qui dysfonctionnent un peu
partout monique lubin 7,7 cette
commission denquête en pleine campagne
présidentielle
est ce que vous y étiez force était
forcément favorable au sein du groupe
socialiste essaie de commission denquête
bon elle a été demandée très rapidement
et après tout pourquoi ne pas saisir les
opportunités qui se présentent mais nous
ce que nous souhaitons et je le dis
toujours au présent nous ce que nous
souhaitons c'est un débat qui aille
beaucoup plus loin sur l' enquête caille
beaucoup plus loin que le contrôle du
contrôle le contrôler alors il faut
expliquer le contrôle du contrôle yade
il ya effectivement l'igas inspection
générale des affaires sociales et
l'inspection générale des finances qui
ont qui ont ouvert des enquêtes voilà
donc nous allons voir comment ils vont
travailler quels moyens leur seront
données j'imagine que c'est ce que je
sais le la direction que va prendre
cette cette mission d'information mais
nous pensons qu'il faut aller au delà
parce que ce livre et les témoignages
qui sortent depuis quelques jours
témoigne de de bien d'autres choses que
des problèmes de maltraitance ils
témoignent de problèmes de maltraitance
mais témoignent aussi d'un système qui
qui qui place des financements privés au
coeur de ces ehpad au lieu de placer les
résidents et on voit quand même des
choses que moi je trouve grave c'est ce
que j'appelle la captation d'argent
public au travers d' économie qui sont
faites sur des personnels soignants sur
le volet dépendance c'est-à-dire de
l'argent versé par la sécurité sociale
et par les départements que l'on
économise pour gonfler les résultats
d'un établissement ce qui sert bien
évidemment à le valoriser et à mieux le
vendre auprès des actionnaires enfin moi
c'est cette marchandisation du grand âge
que je veux que l'on étudie que l'on et
dont je veux que l'on montre vraiment
toutes les facettes
du principe du choix de société et d'un
système à remettre en cause ou pas serge
guérin c'est cette question du du grand
âge elle elle redevient d'enjeux
politiques là dans cette campagne vous
diriez quoi même si c'est horrible même
si les révélations du fil du livre les
fossoyeurs dont on a vu là le la
couverture sont graves est ce que vous
diriez quand même que c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça devienne un enjeu de la
campagne présidentielle oui à d'abord on
pourrait dire il faut ce type de livre
événement joyeux contenu il faut ce type
de livre événement pour que cette
question là reviennent après le risque
c'est qu'on se focalise beaucoup sur les
problèmes et ainsi de suite et puis
qu'on regarde juste et les plus âgés la
question du la société de la longévité
c'est pas seulement les 600000 personnes
qui sont accueillis en maison de
retraite médicalisée cédé 17 millions de
l'iphone qui ont dépassé les 60 ans et
puis c'est nous tous vous et moi qui un
jour ou l'autre on y arrivera donc
tellement on regarde souvent là où on
n'a pas envie de regarder ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que l'effet de
masse incroyable médiatiquement de ce
livre c'est aussi comme s'il y avait une
mauvaise conscience ah tiens on n'a
jamais trop fait attention à la sq est
bien gauche droite sans tout ce qu'on
veut c'est un peu dans le même sac hier
personne est allé voir finalement et à
chaque fois on va et deuxième élément
c'est sur la question des contrôles
j'ai changé tout à l'heure avec un
collègue en allemagne vous aimez
l'allemagne a par exemple deux
organismes de contrôle il ya un
organisme de contrôle régulier sur
comment s'organisent les ehpad puis un
organisme de contrôle qui s'occupe du
bien-être des résidents taxer aussi haut
aussi faire très attention à ne pas
faire que des contrôles quantitative
mais aussi faire du qualitatif le caire
la qualité de vie des personnes quel que
soit mon âge je suis d'abord un citoyen
ou une citoyenne j'ai d'abord un être
humain et j'ai droit à de la dignité
j'ai droit à l'accompagnement est donc
là bas donc il ya plusieurs choses
derrière il ya d'abord quelque chose qui
me dit beaucoup de la société
collectivement oui de nos
journalistes aussi
il ya une forme de refus d'un mois c'est
d'arriver ici même le problème du
d'employer le mot vieux c'est un mot
qu'on n'ose plus employés j'ai décrit
dans le temps un livre qui s'appelait
vivent les vieux pour l'islam à sion à
lui reçu des courriers les uns dix ans a
enfin quelqu'un qui dit vieux des autres
qui me traiter de raciste a laissé ce
truc parce que vieux c'est pas bien si
tu étais sûre et que collectivement
finalement cette situation là on dira
les politiques s'en occupe pas assez de
ça mais c'est de notre faute c'est la
faute de la société qui pousse pas pour
qu'on s'en préoccupe plus et quand on
sort quand on s'en préoccupe plus on se
préoccupe de soi moi je parle souvent
d'égoïsme solidaire ce que finalement
les vieux c est proche d aujourd'hui nos
parents nos grands parents et puis c'est
nous à un moment ou un autre donc il ya
ça aussi et ça marque le fait qu' on a
envie de regarder à côté est là pour se
donner bonne conscience ou presque ont
la mauvaise conscience bien ce coup tout
le monde c'est vrai et tout le monde
s'excite mais c'est tout le temps qu'il
faut et sur ces sujets là alors on
jugerait sur cette notion de système
system qui dysfonctionnent et et donc il
faut rénover transformer radicalement ou
dérivés évidemment cette question elle
est pour vous comme agi seul parce que
depuis les révélations du livre il ya
quand même eu beaucoup de témoignages il
ya eu aussi là on a appris hier ou
avant-hier une une plainte collective
contre un autre géant français des
maisons de retraite qui s'appelle korian
bref on se dit c'est un système qui ne
va pas de la maltraitance et l
systémique dans nos ehpad
à l'évidence si un certain nombre de
pros 2 2 voilà d'éléments dans quête qui
va être révélé qu'ils peuvent montrer un
dysfonctionnement très particulier qui
doit être sanctionné comme il peut en
exister je dirais dans toute profession
bien sûr il faut le faire mais il ne
faut pas que ça masque effectivement ce
sujet de société qui est moqué serge
guérin qui rejaillit à chaque fois qu'il
y à un événement dans ce secteur
d'activité ça a été le par exemple la
question de la gestion de la crise
épidémie et puis avant c'était les
questions de canicule de grippe et il y
encore avant en 2003 la canicule qui
avait particulièrement fait émerger
également le sujet donc on voit bien que
ce sujet tant qu'il n'est pas traitée
par la puissance publique réémerge à
chaque fois est tout simplement parce
que ça touche des millions de français
qu'ils soient personnes âgées
actuellement qu'il soit famille et deux
de ces personnes âgées ou qu'il soit
tout simplement salariés de ce secteur
d'activité et force est de constater
pardon je reprends la main une seconde
pendant douze interrompre à ce que je
vous ai plusieurs fois interviewé depuis
quelques années sur d'autres plateaux
que celui ci et vous alerter
régulièrement sur le manque de moyens
sur les difficultés sur le fait que ya
pas assez de personnel etc etc mais est
ce qu on en est pas arrivé et on peut
dire que la société où les politiques
vous ont pas forcément entendu mais est
ce que vous n'avez pas d'autre choix que
de maltraiter des résidents voyez ce que
je veux dire avec ma question sur le
système
vous avez parfaitement raison et c'est
ce que j'ai essayé de vous décrire parce
que comme nous n'avons pas traité ce
sujet dans le point de vue social d'un
point de vue sociétal et bien force est
de constater que des politiques
vieillesse jusqu'à présent on eu de
cesse que de répondre aux seuls besoins
le premier les personnes âgées c'est à
dire à peu près correctement les nourrir
les laver les soigner ce que nous
faisons à peu près correctement donc de
ce point de vue là les gens ne sont pas
en danger mais par contre il est clair
que c'est largement insuffisant au
regard non seulement des besoins parce
qu'il faudra augmenter ce temps de
présence pour mieux accompagner pour les
temps de repas la toilette etc mais
surtout surtout du point de vue des
attentes de nos concitoyens
les personnes âgées quand nous les
écoutons nous disent mais nous voulons
être et continuer d'être des concitoyens
à part entière et c'est ce modèle je
dirais de solidarité nationale qu'il
convient de construire qu'il n'a pas
jusqu'à présent la question c'est aussi
on va y revenir et ce que le privé est
le mieux placé pour le faire ou pas
est-ce qu'il faut garder à un
fonctionnement à blick lucratif ce sera
évidemment l'un des thèmes du débat ce
qui est un très intéressant l'éthicien
c'est que il ya déjà eu des livres il ya
déjà eu des alertes notamment ses terres
en 2019 c'est ça exactement il
s'appelait toujours les gens harcela et
vous avez dû le voir ces derniers jours
dans les médias qui se sont soit rappelé
en lice soit on fait une rapide
recherche sur internet parce qu'on le
trouve très vite jean marcellin c'est un
ancien directeur d'ehpad dans le sud de
la france il la dirigeait 2 et pâle il
l'a fait par passion parce qu'il a
changé de carrière à 40 ans il était
dans l'automobile et parce que il avait
un amour passionné pour sa grand mère il
a décidé à 40 ans d'aller dans le soin
et donc de diriger des ehpad il n'en a
démissionné thomas avec un livre
tonitruant où il dénonçait déjà tout ce
système vicié des ehpad privé à but
lucratif vous avez raison monsieur est
écouté par exemple ce qu'il disait sur
rtl c'était donc il y a deux ans les
économies principales sont les économies
sur le budget alimentaire il faut savoir
que les grands groupes commerciaux
donnent en moyenne entre 3 euros 70 3
euros 70 et 4 euros 30 par jour pour
nourrir un résident ce qui veut dire que
sur les six cent mille personnes qui
sont actuellement maison de retraite
500000 vont passer le reste de leur vie
a à manger des repas un peu plus d'un
euro on est un peu plus d'un euro par
repas c'est de notoriété publique et ça
ne gêne personne
et donc son livre s'appelle tu verras
maman tu seras bien aux éditions xo il
dénonçait tout ils dénoncent également
le manque de personnel et d'un point de
vue concret puisqu'il était sur le
terrain et donc il expliquait que par
exemple le dimanche il n'avait qu'une
personne en cuisine pour nourrir 120
résidants et il a fait le tour des
médias on l'a reçu on l'a écouté cet
homme et cet ancien directeur des ehpad
mais ni le politique ne s'en est saisi
ni l'opinion publique ne s'en est ému en
tout cas comme comment on connaît
aujourd'hui cette émotion là qui gagne
toute la société le politique juste et
je pense que vous êtes au courant il ya
quand même eu un rapport parlementaire
en 2018 de fiat et iborra de député
c'est noël du sénat 31 mai qui sont
restées lettre morte monsieur le
politique ne s'en est pas saisi pourquoi
aujourd'hui il ya cet émoi politique et
populaire parce que nous sommes
précisément en campagne présidentielle
et que vous avez raison aussi nous
sortons de ces deux années trois années
on ne sait plus de co vide où pour une
fois nous avons parlé des vieux
peut-être avec des questions aussi qui
pouvait paraître discriminatoire quand
il s'agissait de les confiner ou pas en
tout cas il ya eu ce débat sur la table
est donc aujourd'hui oui le politique
s'en empare impossible pour les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle de
faire l'impasse parce que c'est un sujet
qui concerne directement les français
bon bernard bonne on peut dire s'est
jamais trop tard ces voix là
heureusement qu'il ya sourire je sais
pas ça va vraiment changer mais qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ces à ces
critiques à ce que disaient aussi repro
magie zone finalement ça fait des années
voire des décennies on peut on peut
remonter effectivement la canicule de
2003 que cette question elle est sur la
table tant qu'on n'aura pas compris
qu'il faut déjà des moyens
supplémentaires pour les personnes âgées
on n'arrivera pas parce que qu'on le
veuille ou non quand on n'aura pas plus
de personnel et surtout avec une
attractivité qui est quand même loin
d'être satisfaisante on n'arrivera pas
quand même à s'occuper correctement des
personnes âgées et c'est vrai qu'il y
avait des solutions il ya des solutions
qui ont été
des établissements privés à but lucratif
ont les moyens alors c
ces moyens sont généralement j'entends
dire qu'ils se font des économies sur le
dos des résidents ils ont même des aides
de l'état j'essaie libyque alors les
aides publiques sont effectivement
niveau de la médicalisation et même au
niveau des départements puisque d'appât
et distribue aussi individuellement aux
personnes qui sont dans ces
établissements je crois qu'il faut
revoir effectivement tout le système
j'ai été pendant pas mal d'années
président et vice président des affaires
sociales de mon département je sais ce
qu'on a fait au niveau des maisons de
retraite y compris en 2d privé lucratif
je crois on peut pas enfin j'ai enfin
pas donné aujourd'hui les
préconisations qu'on pourra faire à la
suite de la mission mais en moi j'ai
déjà pas mal d'idées sur ce que l'on
pourra proposer en tout cas est qui qui
a été vu diagnostiquer qui est évident
chez beaucoup de personnes et qu'on n'a
pas mis en place je crois qu'il faut
prendre effectivement le taureau par les
cornes aujourd'hui et je pense que c'est
une bonne chose que ce soit sorti au
niveau de ce livre parce que comme vous
disiez justement y ait eu beaucoup de
d'articles claude evin je crois en 2014
avait déjà signalé ces problèmes énormes
donc il ya le livre de l'océan cela qui
est sorti après il ya des rapports qui
ont été fait là aussi au niveau du sénat
parce qu'on en a fait 2 à 2 2 puis 2018
qui ont aussi démontré qu'il fallait
changer complètement ce système qu'il
fallait modifier qu'il fallait
certainement aussi modifier les ehpad et
peut-être trouver des systèmes à
domicile beaucoup plus important mais
tout ça on va essayer de le montrer de
faire des propositions dans le cadre du
rapport parce qu'on va pas se contenter
de regarder le contrôle du contrôle oui
mais mais mais vous vous représenter
une et l'autre des partis politiques qui
ont été au pouvoir dans ces 15 dernières
années donc cette réforme pas grandes
dépenses elle a pas non plus le jeu
prend de la même question à l'un et à
l'autre et peut-être final ils répondent
aussi pendant le quinquennat de de
françois hollande n'y a pas eu non plus
la grande réforme sur le grand âge et la
dépendance alors il n'y a pas eu la
grande réforme sur le grand âge et la
dépendance mais je vais rappeler aussi
sans chercher du mauvaise excuse parce
que personne est excusable sur le sujet
que nous étions dans une situation qui
n'est quand même pas tout à fait la même
que celle de ceux de cette mandature qui
s'achève où on n'a cessé de nous répéter
que tout allait beaucoup mieux ce que je
constate la politique c'est une question
de choix et même dans une période où ça
va beaucoup mieux le choix n'a pas été
porté sur les personnes âgées et sur la
dépendance pour ce qui me concerne je
suis élu d'un département un peu
atypique et même carrément atypique
puisque nous n'avons aucun groupe privé
voilà nous avons des ehpad qui sont
gérés exclusivement par le secteur
public ou par le secteur privé non
lucratif
je ne dis pas que c'est parce que nous
sommes dans le privé qu'il n'y a pas de
phénomènes de maltraitance ou de ou de
sentiment d'abandon des résidents ou des
choses comme ça vous dit quoi vous dis
que c'est pas forcément mieux parce que
ces salaires n'est pas j'ai dansé sur 10
quand même je dis quand même
contrairement à ce que m'a répondu
monsieur véran la semaine dernière que
c'est documenté le taux le ratio agents
résidant est nettement meilleure dans le
public que dans le privé ça c'est quand
même documenté il me dit que ce n'est
pas vrai mais c'est vrai ça c'est une
première chose donc ça veut dire plus de
personnes de personnel pour s'occuper
d'un résidence et 0,76 pour un résident
dans le public pour 0,62 dans le privé
par ailleurs puisque dans les landes
nous n'avons pas de priver voilà j'ai
même lu 0,55 dans le privé donc on
marche je sais quoi je parle sous votre
contrôle surgir en allemagne c'est un
pour un oui en allemagne ensuite
réplique à la presse qu'un poids d'après
faut y revenir parce que on mélange
parfois un peu et torchons et les
serviettes mais bon ça répond quels sont
les métiers qui sont tous à vis des
horaires
quantitatif
je n'avais pas terminer mon propos le
l'avantagent de la gestion publique
c'est qu'évidemment on n'a pas c'est ce
que j'appelle des débordements il ces
abus qui font que on va gagner
énormément d'argent sur le dos de
personnes âgées voilà par contre il
manque effectivement de personnel dans
le privé et dans le public aussi l'idéal
ça serait un pur effectivement et la
maltraitance elle peut survenir juste
parce qu'il manque de personnel et que
les personnels ne peuvent pas travailler
du coup dans de bonnes conditions
la maltraitance eux ça n'est pas
forcément frappé des personnes âgées je
vais je vais la maltraitance c'est juste
ne pas avoir le temps de 5,2 de leur
parler ne pas avoir le temps ne pas leur
laisser le temps nécessaire aux bourses
pour leur repas raconte depuis deux
semaines rassure des passionnés la
nourrice à moi c'est un bouchon et ça
n'est pas que ça ça n'est pas que c'est
assez c'est le temps qu'on ne leur
accorde pas c'est la fille qu'on ne leur
donne pas faim la question c'est de
savoir si on rajoute de la vie aux
années où des années à la vie si ça la
question si vous faites un comparatif
public privé vous dites quoi d'abord
vous rappeler une chose toute bête ou
s'il privé est là c'est parce que l'état
n'a pas fait le boulot on est d'accord
le privé il est par ici pas imposer
comme sa commune c'est l'état nous
collectivement qui arrondit renens donné
on n'est pas allé pas les i donc si
privé arrive aux biocides y trouve son
équilibre économique
il est arrivé comme ça j'entends les
jambes à nationaliser tout ça chaque
vendeur est connu huit mois comment on
fait ça c'est un deuxième sujet met donc
à cette réalité la première deuxième
réalité si on regarde au défenseur des
droits il ya 50 % des plaintes qui
viennent du public est un exemple
présente à peu près 50% des ehpad ont de
ce point de vue là on peut faire 10 de
l'idéologie ça fait plaisir mais la
réalité les paye tous les mois je dirige
un master jai des étudiants femmes
hommes et tout ça de tous les âges y
compris dans notre des gens en
reconversion qui cherchent du sens en
effet et le mans ce que je vois à chaque
fois c'est pareil c'est beaucoup une
question de personnes c'est le premier
cours jeudi aujourd'hui je vous rappelle
que les êtres humains là ce ne sont pas
des petits pois ce sont des êtres
humains et deux fois des êtres humains
parce que les gens très fragiles qui
sont cons accueil et puis à les
personnels qui sont d'ailleurs parfois
aussi en difficulté économique autres et
alors c'est le privilège ou mais en
gardant un perron tombée est-ce que la
logique du privé fait qu'on les
considère plus comme des petits pois que
la logique du public n'ont pas forcément
pas du tout bon c'est vraiment beau pas
j'ai pas dire au contraire je veux pas
rentrer en scène mais parce qu'à mon
sens elle est complètement rigide
complètement idéologique ça dépendra de
la personnalité du directeur de grandes
bases de l'êta l'organisation évidemment
aussi mais globalement vous êtes dans un
établissement vous changez de direction
ou associatifs publics ou privés mais ça
peut être le jour et la nuit donc dans
les deux sens dit que ce n'est pas le
système lui-même qui a gangréné planète
alors le système a besoin d'être
contrôlé ça je crois qu'il ya vraiment
un sujet on est un des pays où il ya le
plus de subventions publiques iliad - de
contrôle ça c'est quand même pas très
cohérent pays comme l'italie on avait
calculé c'est tous les huit ans où les
ars vont contrôler un établissement
public ou privé d'accord on avait
calculé il faut 41 ans pour évaluer les
7500 là évidemment ça ça ça va pas et
puis la rs et réduit du contrôle
quantitatif il ya aussi la qualité bazar
de sorts vivre dans un lieu comme ça il
faut d'abord penser à la qualité vie on
va pas rendre les gens plus jeunes dans
ce coup c'est pas ça le sujet c'est
comment on fait que leur qualité de vie
soit la meilleure possible et celle
aussi des personnels parfois les
personnels ils sont aussi en difficulté
3 sur nous ces éléments extrêmement
pendant derrière tout ça c'est la
question de comment on a vendu une
société de la longévité sur tous les
âges comment on pense en termes de
prévention en termes de guerre c'est ça
les enjeux et là dedans la question des
personnels la question des métiers elle
est absolument centrale et on peut faire
toutes les lois qu'on voudra il ya pour
l'instant il nous manque cinq cent mille
personnes donc tant qu'on n'aura pas les
gens pour venir travailler dans le
secteur on peut raconter ce qu'on veut
sur des là ou là où on veut l'arrêté
c'est que ya pas assez de gens qui ont
envie on leur donne peut-être pas assez
envie de venir y travailler bah c'est un
autre sujet là il ya vraiment un sujet
autour de cela vous parliez du contrôle
cette commission
dans quelle est là aussi pour ça je
propose à quand un kilomètre de nous
rejoindre bonsoir quentin
qu'est ce qu'on pensait d'eux de cette
commission aujourd'hui ce qui est
certain thomas c'est que les sénateurs
vont vouloir éviter ce qui s'est passé
mercredi dernier à l'assemblée nationale
avec l'audition du nouveau pdg d'orpea
et du directeur général d'orpea france
vous les voyez l'image on avait entendu
les députés sidéré de n'avoir aucune
réponse précise voire pire à lorsqu'il
s'agissait de répondre aux accusations
du livre-enquête que vous avez évoqué
sur ce plateau écouter ce qu'elle peut
dire philippe charrier la semaine
dernière donc face à l'assemblée
nationale y aurait un système orpea qui
consisterait à
optimiser le profit pour rogner sur nos
prestations ce système n'existe en aucun
cas dans nos ehpad chez opéra philippe
qui sépare les uns d'erreurs
individuelles de certains est salarié
les députés avaient alors été très
critique de ce niveau de réponse écouter
un petit une petite collection qu'on a
qu'on a fait il faut que vous ne
répondiez parce que je vous écoute
depuis une heure et vous ne répondez à
rien du tout je vous avoue être outré
par cette audition par la qualité ou
l'absence de réponse sur un certain
nombre de sujets clairement et beauté
vraiment on arrêté là puisque la
représentation nationale je vous le dis
franchement vous cache pas est déçu de
la qualité de vos réponses ou l'absence
de réponse qu'est ce qui permet de dire
que ça va mieux se passer ici au sénat
eh bien les sénateurs veulent pouvoir
aller plus loin en actant le fait qu'ils
ont les pouvoirs d'une commission
denquête et donc ça ç'a bien été acté ce
soir par le sénat il dispose du pouvoir
de faire prêter serment et de convoquer
les personnes qui ont l'obligation de se
présenter les sénateurs vont pouvoir a
également effectué des visites et
demandé des documents et ça il est
obligatoire de les fournir lorsqu'on
vous les demandes pour appelle
d'ailleurs à la peine encourue pour un
délit de parjure c'est-à-dire un faux
témoignage devant une commission enquête
ces cinq ans d'emprisonnement et de
75000 euros d'amendé un moyen aussi au
passage pour le sénat de doubler un peu
à l'assemblée nationale qui attendent
toujours de savoir s'ils vont pouvoir et
bien avoir une commission denquête ils
vont auditionner demain les agences l'
agence régionale de santé est l'auteur
du livre enquête et autre point
important les sénateurs vont lancer leur
commission denquête à la fin du mois de
février et pouvoir travailler comme cela
pendant le mois de mars ils ne vont pas
devoir s'arrêter avec la suspension des
travaux parlementaires même si c'est le
cas au parlement et de sessions en
séance publique qui vont pouvoir
continuer leurs auditions pendant la
campagne présidentielle merci quentin
pour toutes ces précisions bernard bonne
ça peut durer combien de temps une
commission comme principe une commission
denquête dure six mois là on nous a
demandés jamais prévu aussi de la sphère
de ne terminer avant l'été donc avant
l'été on aura terminé la plupart des
auditions j'aurais on aura beaucoup plus
de temps effectivement comme ça a été
dit puisqu'on a on a plus de travaux au
niveau du sénat donc ça va nous
permettre d'auditionner un maximum de
personnes et comment disait tout à
l'heure on va pas se contenter du
contrôle du contrôle on va essayer
d'aller un peu plus loin de faire des
préconisations et ils ont aidé préconisé
qui sont eux mêmes étant d'abord comment
vous faites nommé pour expliquer aux
téléspectateurs comment on fait quand on
est parlementaire ont fourni un faux nez
un travail d' enquêtes ont fourni en
vinyle mesures ont prouvé les
préconisations comment on force
l'exécutif à les appliquer parce que
c'est bien ça la question il fait un
moment pouvoir changer et si ce qu'on se
demande quand on vous écoute et mais
vous savez c'est le rôle malheureux
quelquefois des parlementaires qui
travaille beaucoup et notamment au
niveau du sénat qui font beaucoup de
rapports beaucoup de propositions qui ne
sont pas toujours assez entendu et je
pense que là la pression
politique et public est tel que je pense
que les préconisations comme de qu'on
fera à la fin de l'été je vous dis quel
que soit le gouvernement deux feront
absolument aboutir à quelque chose lors
des relais médiatiques associatif alors
on essaiera d abord je voudrais pas
qu'il ya une pression médiatique trop
importante pour qu'il ait une neutralité
une objectivité pendant tout le temps
des travaux mais il y aura certainement
l'utilisation des médias pour faire
avancer les choses cette loi grand âge
en face à fait moi j'ai été rapporteur
du médico social pendant trois ans puis
après j'ai voulu passer la main à
agoniser tout à l'heure je ne m'occupais
de la protection de l'enfance je reviens
un peu sur nan mais personnes âgées et
je vous garantis que cette fois on va
faire des préconisations et puis on va
faire en sorte que ce soit connue et
acceptée mais il faut un consens donne
les moyens parce que c'est quand même
une question de moyens et de moyens et
qu'on accepte au niveau de notre pays de
dire comme dans d'autres pays c'est
important de s'occuper de nos personnes
âgées vous savez j'étais aussi en dehors
des deux côtés politique j'étais médecin
pendant pas mal d'années et je
m'occupais aussi le maison de retraite à
l'époque maison de retraite à l'époque
c'était irait aussi des tas de choses à
revoir qu'on essayait de revoir on
essayait dervin dans son domaine c'est
pour ça que tout n'est pas mauvais
partout on ne peut pas dire ça il faut
améliorer au maximum tout ce qu'on peut
faire et notamment donc vous le disiez
le système de contrôle est pour
l'instant insuffisant allez on va le
dire comme ça c'est très
surtout je crois qu'il ya une fois c'est
un choix de société mais est ce que on
estime qu'en termes de vie en commun
est-ce qu'on estime qu'en termes
d'avenir collectif la question des âges
est importante ou est-ce qu'on abandonne
et derrière ça il ya la question de
financement là a été voté le principe du
cinquième risque qui est quand même une
avancée très fort parce que pour une
fois on dit attention il faut fléchi de
l'argent tu en flèche de l'argent faire
aussi d'où il vient à la csg ou crds
question d'impôts et tout ça mais
derrière tout ça il ya on peut voir le
côté des charges il faut les voir mais
vous faut aussi voir le levier
économique le levier d'emplois le levier
de qualité de vie si vous êtes à neydens
et s'il ya plus de personnes pour vous
aider bien plus de professionnels mais
votre vie avoue elle va s'améliorer
voilà si on travaille plus sur la
prévention on y loue à une low risk on
le réduit parle on ne supprime pas bien
sûr on ilwan le risque de la maladie les
noms qu'on va faire des économies à la
société ont fait une visite on fait
d'abord de l'humanité d'assurer ensuite
en plus économiques quand les deux vont
ensemble c'est comme génial et ça et on
a on à mourouj à l'excellence sujet de
campagne présidence des meilleurs sujets
de campagne présidentielle avant l'été
mme enfin il faudrait peut-être
j'en sais rien je peins politique mais
bon j'imagine qu'un levier de pression
pendant cette campagne serait quand même
candidat les auditions seront médiatisé
je voudrais donner deux éléments dans
dans ce débat d'abord depuis les
révélations du livre les fossoyeurs les
témoignages affluent notamment où 39 77
le 39 77 et le numéro de signalements de
maltraitance envers les personnes âgées
il y en a en ce moment 50 par jour et
ces deux fois plus qu'avant la sortie du
livre donc ça c'est un premier élément
sur le nombre de signalements et puis on
peut imaginer ce que ça pourrait donner
derrière je sais qu'on va voir sur quoi
ça ça débouche et puis alors il ya un
autre élément que je voudrais poser
proposé faire avancer le débat c'est un
témoignage témoignage d'un ancien
juriste en alternance chez orpea et là
on est vraiment dans la mécanique des
contrôles et peut-être ça rejoint ce que
ce qu'ont ressenti les députés ce que
racontait quentin tout à l'heure c'est
de sentiment peut-être un peu d'impunité
chez certains
établissements ou chez certains acteurs
du privé on écoute qui a motivé ce
témoignage c'est vraiment le choc qu'a
procuré cette intégration dans le sein
des services rh mais aussi le choc qui a
été de découvrir à quel point e se
sentaient intouchables et l'étai puisque
finalement toutes les alertes qui a été
lancé par les syndicats tous les
déplacements de l'inspection du travail
n'aboutissait à aucune sanction
camille la marche qui est donc une
ancienne juriste on l'a bien compris
roma gizolme moi ce qui me frappe dans
ce témoignage mais aussi dans dans le
livre les fossoyeurs c'est ce sentiment
d'impunité cette impression que mon
balai contrôlons certains directeurs ils
sont prévenus avant et donc il peut
évidemment proposer la meilleure image
de leur établissement
il ya là aussi il ya deux choses
certainement à distinguer moi je ne suis
ni l'avocat
ni le représentant de torpédo de ces
messieurs que je ne connais pas donc je
pense que les commentaires des membres
de la commission ont été suffisamment
parlants pour par eux-mêmes pour ce qui
concerne ce point là ensuite il ya un
élément sur la question de la qualité
aussi des contrôles aujourd'hui que
voulez-vous que la puissance publique
viennent contrôler c'est la puissance
publique qui va définir qui va vous
donner une enveloppe qui va vous est
alloué une enveloppe pour déterminer le
nombre de professionnels que vous allez
mettre au quotidien auprès des personnes
âgées dans l'établissement que vous
dirigez quand bien même elle vient et
que tout était préparé que voulez-vous
qu'elle constate si ce n'est qu'elle que
les personnes âgées sont insuffisamment
accompagné que les professionnels sont
surmenés et épuisés dont il donc en fait
tout simplement parce qu'elle ne finance
pas suffisamment ce secteur d'activité
donc vous voyez il ya aussi ces
questions là à revoir pour les contrôles
par exemple pour pourrait imaginer qu'il
soit beaucoup plus efficace ah s'il
était envisagé comme dans le secteur de
la petite enfance où vous avez des ratio
minimum de professionnels à mettre à
disposition qui sont clairement
déterminées par la puissance publique
est en deçà desquels votre structure
risque soit d'être sanctionnés voire
d'être fermé eh bien nous n'avons de
cesse que depuis des années et demandé à
la puissance publique de fixer ses ratio
minimum et 2 les tenir et ensuite une
fois que nous aurons réhausser le niveau
de qualité générale de ce secteur
d'activité quel que soit le statut
juridique des établissements eh bien
nous pourrons voir effectivement si les
services qui sont proposés sont bien en
rapport avec les standards qui seront
établies de façon correcte
monique lubin de donc on garde le privé
mais en contre le mieux est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec cette idée
ouais vous simplifiez la considère que
les exemples que l'ona d'orpea et et
autres démontrent que le privé n'a rien
à faire dans dans dans la gestion des
ehpad et
comment financer tout à l'heure
d'idéologie moi j'appelle ça des choix
politique c'est pas tout à fait nous
nous séparons nous ça n'est pas une
idéologie ce sont des choix politique
que nous assumons et économiquement
combien ça coûterait mais économiquement
ça se tient enfin nous y arrivons aucun
aucun nepad mais déficitaire chez nous
mongi arrivant c'est à dire que le prix
de journée est fixée on a mis deux bars
qui est autour de 65 euros par jour le
prix de journée est fixée on à la
dépendance on a le la sécurité sociale
qui paie le personnel soignant et tout
ça et ensuite on a toute la partie
hébergement
donc on y arrive on a même voté il ya
deux semaines au département on a voté
une dotation financière que l'on va
attribuer aux employeurs c'est à dire
ccas qui n'ont pas ce qu'ils font là
riez de public non pas une droit au
fameux avenant 43 les 183 euros qui ont
été attribués personnel des structures
associatif type chez moi c'est les
associations dead en milieu rural les
admr je pense que c'est connu dans
d'autres départements
les salariés du public n'ont pas eu
droit eh bien nous dans le département
nous avons voté une dotation financière
que nous allons attribués à ses
employeurs qui eux mêmes ne peuvent pas
de manière à ce qu'il a ce qu'ils
augmentent leurs salaires voilà donc
s'avouer 950 euros par mois pardon ça
fait 1950 euros par mois 65 euro par
jour c'est ça ce sera le tarif là là
vous me parlez du prix du prix de tous
les résidents j'en ai tant aux salaires
là
c'est pas du tout les chiffres qu'on
entend dans le privé ou non je vais vous
dire on est au maximum on est au maximum
à 2000 euros par mois sur les dernières
sur les derniers epad que l'on a faits
qui sont des ehpad donc 9 et enfin voilà
extrêmement agréable à vivre en bas on
est oui bien sûr qu'il y à un gap est
une autre différence ça n'est pas de
l'idéologie mais des choix politiques
c'est que toulouse ait pas de nous ils
sont habilités à l'aide sociale qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire que
cantat n'est pas de priver demande de
3000 à ce que j'ai entendu six mille
enfin bon des sommes un peu mais voilà
un notebook et bien ils ne sont pas
habilités à l'aide sociale ça veut dire
quoi l'aide sociale ça veut dire que
lorsque le résident ne peut pas payer
lorsque sa famille et n'existent pas ou
qu'elle ne peut pas payer
c'est le collectif qui paient pour lui
c'est le département qui paie pour lui
ce qui permet à tout un chacun d'avoir
accès à un ehpad quel que soit son
niveau et même source le problème c'est
que si on paye moins si on paye et
moelleux si on est à moins de 2000 on va
on va le payer en impôt innovation d'une
autre machine alors messi il faudra bien
c'est que selon les départements est ce
que la situation n'est pas la même est
ce que je peux vous expliquer mais où il
ya pas d'argent public supplémentaires
il n'y a pas de dotation supplément vous
avez les racheter ou des nationalismes
vous me parlez des ehpad privé ben oui
mais pas de priver actuelle alors moi ma
tendance à manquer quoi maman bon mot ni
dit à moi ça serait on peut pas aller
racheter vous imaginez bah oui bah oui
il l'a fait l'action l'action avec moi
je serais pour ne plus attribuer à
partir de maintenant aucun agrément à
des ehpad privé et de promouvoir les
ehpad publics ou les ehpad privé à les
urnes on l'écrasera dit là-dessus
bernard bret plupart des alors pour
avoir dirigé un département jeudi assez
longtemps la plupart des ehpad privé à
but lucratif et moi je n'avais
pratiquement pas ne sont pas habilités à
l'aide sociale dont il ya un mois le
problème du contrôle c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on contrôle les
établissements les départements contrôle
par rapport à l'aide sociale les
dotations à l'aide sociale qui sont
données et par rapport au prix de la
deûle a pas un lapin qui en dotation
globale et puis la rs contrôler ce
qu'ils émettent médicalisation nous donc
tous les établissements publics et
privés a privés associatifs ou privés à
but non lucratif sont contrôlés
complètement il ya des départements dans
le mien où j'avais mis des contrôles
inopinés tous les ans dans tous les
établissements dont on dépend des parts
contre des établissements pub peuvent
être privées à but lucratif ne sont pas
contrôlés effectivement parce que
l'argent public et donnés
individuellement à la personne et on ne
peut pas en am je sais même pas si sur
le plan légal on a le droit d'aller les
contrôler directement c'est là où il
faudra peut-être revoir les choses il
faut qu'on puisse penser
le faire mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est un ya des différences selon les
départements ce qui est quand même un
sujet oui selon vous habitez c'est pavel
chaussures que vous avez parfaitement
raison c'est aussi des choix ses choix
ou on met l'argent alors du coup on
décide de mettre plus d'argent il faut
aussi trouver l'argent dont on apprend
postollec avec 6,3 à pau l'habitation à
l'aide sociale le privé on a aussi ils
ont même des obligations de ce point de
vue là voilà mais le triple but lucratif
la but lucratif non et puis les prix je
suis pas là pour défendre là où l'eau
c'est pas ça pour prendre un sujet si je
regarde comment les gens vivaient encore
une fois je vois beaucoup l'humain
derrière tout ça faut aussi rappeler
bien sûr la raison de dire et quand il
ya des choses inadmissibles faut le dire
et c'est dégueulasse y a pas d'autre mot
en plus c'est les gens qui sont déjà
fragiles on profite de leur fragilité
comme ça qu'a derrière mais rappelons
aussi qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui à
bien des wii d'abord il ya plein de
choses ça se passe très bien du
dévouement j'ai suivi régulier ce qui
met plus proche qui est non j'y suis pas
où je le vois aussi mais ce que je veux
dire aussi c'est que les deux tiers des
maltraitances elle se passe dans les
familles faut pas oublier c'est pas que
les méchants dans un coin c'est aussi
qu'est notre rapport à l'âge qu'elle
notre rapport à la fragilité alors il ya
celle des plus âgées mais aussi celle
des autres personnes qui sont fragiles
en perte d'autonomie qui est derrière
tout ça il ya ça comment nous tous
collectivement on regarde on se soutient
on accompagne les plus fragiles en
sachant que les plus fragiles c'est les
autres puis un jour c'est nous c'est
parce que là la démographie ne ment pas
il faut dire c'est quoi de la génération
de première génération baby boom c'est
ça arrive à 80 ans vous avez raison dans
le prochain ça aussi c'est en lien des
retrouvailles avec la politique le
prochain quinquennat va voir arriver
2026 la première génération des baby
boomers qui vont avoir plus 80 ans il à
l'explosion pendant 30 ans depuis 80 ans
donc c'est là on est dans le mur c'est
un peu comme le réchauffement climatique
ou là comme ça chauffe pour ça pour
s'inquiéter là c'est pareil on est dans
le mur allez ce que je voulais je n'ai
pas pu terminer tout alors mon
raisonnement ça n'est pas la question de
l'impôt c'est la question de l'argent
que l'on consacre à travers le budget de
la sécurité sociale à ces ehpad donc ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas l'impôt d'une
certaine façon c'est la part qu'on y
accorde l argent de la sécurité sociale
ça n'est pas si on en met plus le jeu
n'est pas bon on en mettra moins
ailleurs donc mais alors justement les
choix politiques réside là tout ce qu'on
peut se raconter là autour de cette
table excusez moi c'est du vent main si
on n'y met pas la première des
conditions la condition sinequanone quel
budget allons nous consacrer dans les
années à venir dans le point dans la loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale à
l'accompagnement des personnes âgées ça
n'est que ça et pour l'instant je me
permets de dire lorsque j'entends
certains candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
enfin il va falloir serrer les vis je
vous avoue que je suis très inquiète
pour les personnes âgées voilà je pense
que pour l'instant on se paye de mots
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat serge rigal un
rappel le titre de votre livre au
service de la vie et métiers du service
à la personne et il est publié aux
éditions fauves merci a bientot merci à
tous merci roma gizolme évidemment à
vous aussi d'avoir participé à ce débat